how did the two of you become involved
with alter egos you have to audition or
you just chosen chosen we were actually
was actually written for us we had
worked with Jordan gallon before in his
first film and when he sat down to kind
of start this process with with alter
egos he rode with us in mine and I think
he can touch base with us before we even
really started writing it kind of
pitched the idea to us and see if we if
we if it can't spoke to us and kind of
we help let us kind of influence where
we thought we won't wanted our
characters to kind of go with it so and
we're kind of involved from the from a
get go with it was nice did that is true
that is true what he says is true is it
what yeah we were involved but i
remember it was right around Christmas
time I feel like I've talking to Jordan
almost daily yeah however many years ago
this was about he would you know email
the script over and then you would have
ideas about it and Jordan would
contribute look changed a little bit and
I'd read it and we get on the phone
immediately he was you know we were
going back and forth and talking almost
daily for a while there and he he i
think he really wanted to make sure that
you and I both wanted to do it because
that that was a big part of actually
doing the whole phone was that he just
with the three of us were going to get
together again and when we worked on the
movie the first film that joy was
talking about rosencrantz and
guildenstern are I'm dead i we we had
upset I mean at least speaking for
myself we had to I have such a great
time working on that movie and where he
would Jordan I love the way Jordan works
and i believe thought the movie was
funny and and and i think he did too
when i'm sure you know a good time and
so it was just like really kind of like
hungry to like get back and just find me
I would have done if Jordan had said I
have no script whatsoever we're going
out to the middle of the desert we'll be
shooting for three months I don't know
come back I go to sit her what to do it
why not just touching the right habits
yeah I love working with Jordan yeah it
was we had a good time where it was kind
of messed around with a script a little
bit and you know do a couple takes that
were a little bit looser and you know so
it was it was it was easy leave a lot of
fun with each other
you